Narrator: Tonight on the season
finale of "Shark Tank"...
If you think starting
a business is tough,
try doing it
with your kid.
[ Laughter ]
It's not that kind
of show, guys.
You are right on that.
[ Laughs ]
We made $3.3 million.
Wow.
You're a machine!
I'm a little bit delusional
when it comes to business.
How many have you sold?
We've sold like 1,500 so far.
That's terrible.
How are you surviving?
This is getting de-listed.
The numbers are insane.
I made the number up.
Why do you need a Shark?
I don't have it in me
to build another company.
What would you give up
for all the Sharks?
John: Hey, Kevin, hold on.
Kevin.
What's going on
with Lori?
♪♪
Narrator: First in the Tank
is a social media star
who created a business poking
fun at social media stars.
♪♪
What's up, Sharks?
I'm Tank Sinatra.
I'm from New York.
I make memes, and I spread
good news for a living.
And I'm here seeking $500,000
in exchange for a whopping 10%
equity stake in my company,
Influencers in the Wild:
The Game.
Now, let's start
with the basics.
Some of you --
How do I say this? --
older, more wonderful Sharks
might be wondering,
"Tank, what is an influencer?"
Well, you see that girl
over there trying to snap
the perfect picture of herself,
distracting everyone around her?
That is an influencer.
It's all about gaining followers
on social media.
So I took the idea
of influencers
and Internet culture
in general
and built a board game
around that.
Introducing Influencers
in the Wild: The Game.
Go places, gain followers,
get famous,
no talent required.
It re-imagines
the classic board game,
except in our game, you rack up
followers instead of money.
Players make their way
around the board
one roll of the die at a time,
and just like in real life,
the player with
the most followers wins.
So, Sharks, who wants to use
their influence and money --
Let's keep it real,
that's why I'm here --
to make this the best-selling
board game of all time?
Corcoran: You gonna show us
how it works?
Yeah, how do you play?
Of course, yeah.
You're actually -- You're
being a little distracting.
There's a room back there
with great lighting.
If you want to go back there
and take some selfies,
that would be fantastic.
Thank you so much.
Thanks for your help.
Alright, so,
that was Chloe.
She's, like, a legit,
OG influencer.
Are you an influencer?
How many followers
does she have?
Yeah, Tank is big time
on Instagram.
I follow him. Tank Sinatra is,
like, the real deal.
Well, tell me about yours,
because I do not follow you.
Sinatra: Sure.
You do follow me.
You follow Tank's Good News.
Oh, you're Tank's Good News.
John: Oh!
Alright, alright, alright.
I follow you, as well.
I'm gonna have
to follow you, Tank.
You're making the world
a better place
with the content
you put out.
I mean, I've been a "Shark Tank"
viewer since season one.
I would not be where I am today
if it wasn't for "Shark Tank."
I learned more
watching this show...
Then this is your moment
on the carpet.
...than anything.
So let's get back...
Yeah.
Alright.
How do you play it?
So, you pick
an influencer playing piece,
you put it on Start,
you roll the die.
And I picked these
influencer travel hotspots
like Bali, Tulum,
the desert rave.
You end at the Big Pink Wall,
which is like the influencer
mecca in Los Angeles.
Heh.
And you travel around the board,
and you can lose followers
along the way,
gain followers along the way.
All of the fun
is on the blue spaces.
So when you land
on a blue space,
you have blue playing cards.
Okay. I just landed on a blue
space, and it says, "Catfish.
Someone uses your photos
on a dating app.
Gain 50K followers."
'Cause that means you're hot.
So at the end of the game,
I tally up my followers.
And whoever's
got the most...
Wins.
...I win.
Exactly. Yep.
I love this.
"Don't talk to me.
I'm verified."
Exactly. So, you know --
Tank, tell us about yourself.
How'd you get
involved in this?
I love comedy, I love sales,
I love "Shark Tank,"
and I love Jay-Z, and that's it.
[ Laughter ]
But I don't love being subject
to the whims of the algorithm,
to be honest,
to make my living.
So I think a physical product
is a smart way to expand
instead of just growing
my following,
because that's what I am
focused on all the time.
Right. So, I mean,
I give you credit.
You've got a great feel
for what's going on,
but tell me about
the business side.
So we're, like,
so new at this.
We just signed an exclusive deal
with a big-box retailer.
So if someone walks in,
and they're going to see
Influencers in the Wild,
how are they going to know
what that is, right?
And what's gonna
get them to buy?
So, we watched what happened
with Cards Against Humanity
and What Do You Meme?
They were at the same
price point as us --
But they were
small card games, right?
So it was easy to pick up
and give as a gift.
But they were also based
on an Internet meme.
Right.
So it's the same
kind of thing.
We want to educate people,
which is one of the barriers
we faced.
I'm a little bit delusional
when it comes to business.
I thought we were going to sell
a million copies on day one,
even though we only had
64,000 in stock.
Every entrepreneur
thinks that.
You know?
Then they said,
"Hey, we don't want it for Q4,
we want it for Q3.
We're going to put them
on an end cap.
You know what? We want them on
the Back To College end cap."
Oh, boy, yeah.
Then when I started
advertising,
I saw that most of our clicks
were from 25 to 44.
So I was like, "Back To College
is not even our demographic."
How many have you sold?
We've sold like 1,500 so far.
Oh. Alright.
That's terrible.
But how many doors
were you in of that --
1,900.
-Oof.
-Wow.
Yeah, it's not good.
It's not selling enough.
This is getting de-listed.
♪♪
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in,
but they are concerned about
Tank's low sales
for his social media-inspired
board game,
Influencers in the Wild.
It's not selling enough.
This is getting de-listed.
It's not giving them enough
margin per linear foot.
That's what's
gonna happen.
Sinatra: Perhaps.
It's only been two months.
The margins,
in my opinion, are good.
Maybe --
Well, tell us the numbers.
Tell us the numbers.
We can get them from anywhere
from $4.97 to $5.47,
depending on
how many we buy.
And you sell it in
at what?
We retail
at direct to consumer at $30,
we sell it at the big-box
retailer at $13.31,
but that's through a broker.
We sell it to them at 38%.
That's a decent margin.
Yeah, decent for you.
Yeah, but what were your sales
direct to consumer?
We haven't sold any
direct to consumer.
How many dollars have you sold
worth of product?
The broker has sold $140,000
worth of goods.
It's -- We're gonna sell
these games, I have no doubt.
The feet -- my wife said,
"The game is getting
its little tootsies wet."
That's what happens.
But is there any other
information
that's going to justify
a $5 million valuation?
We're so new,
I made the number up.
I'll be dead honest with you.
Like, it's not a real number.
The problem is,
you picked the wrong number.
Coming in asking for $500K,
the numbers are insane.
There's just
no way to say,
"Okay, this is
a good investment,"
based off of what
you've told us so far.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
You know, I spent some time
in the toy industry.
The big guys, they get thousands
of submissions, thousands,
and 1 in 100 take off.
It's really, really hard.
I think you're a good guy,
but we all are influencers.
I've got millions
of followers.
When I invest in a product,
I get behind it,
which I would have loved
to have done on this one.
But I gotta write a check
for $500,000
to get involved with you?
That's crazy.
I'm not gonna do it.
I'm out.
Okay.
Why don't you think
it's worth $5 million?
Because you're
not making money.
Not yet.
Yeah, but you want us
to put our money today
based on your potential
in the future.
That's asking a lot.
We have no idea
how this is gonna sell.
Everybody's saying,
if you had come in
asking for $50K, $80K, $100K,
we'd take a flier on you.
I couldn't do that, though,
because when we go into Walmart,
they're gonna want $350,000
for 56,000 games.
That's not our problem.
No, but, Tank, see,
that's where you missed it.
You don't watch enough
"Shark Tank," right?
For us to get back
$500,000...
Yeah.
...you have to generate
$5 million
in after-tax cash flow.
Yeah.
Generating $5 million
in after-tax cash flow is
hard.
You have to do about
$50 million in sales.
You've gotta do
so much in sales,
and that's just
getting our money back.
Well, I understand
that your money is real,
and I respect that,
and you want to get it back --
Why would I just want
my money back?
If I give you $500,000,
I want $5 million back.
I want a 10X.
That was the mistake
on this deal.
You asked too much.
Yeah.
You know,
I love social media.
I would love
to have gotten behind it
and supported it, and --
You're speaking in past tense.
I don't like that.
[ Laughter ]
But here,
I have no idea
if people are gonna
enjoy this game or like it.
It's just way too much money
for me to risk.
So, unfortunately, Tank,
while I love
you,
I'm out.
Let me give you another
point of view on the valuation.
So, all of us are very --
get pitched a lot.
We can easily look
for game developers.
As Kevin said,
there's thousands of them.
And for $500,000,
we can probably acquire
a 70% or 90% position
on something that has not
been discovered.
And that's the biggest
challenge for us.
But right now,
this is too rich for me.
I'm out.
Yeah, thank you.
The best thing about you as
an individual and a businessman
that I know of
is you're quick-witted.
Everything you do
is so succinct and punchy
and makes people laugh.
But to me, I think
you're just asking us all --
and I think you've heard that
over and over again --
To take a chance card
on 1,500 sold,
you're asking a lot,
so I'm out.
Alright.
Hey, Tank...
Cuban: Good luck, man.
Thank you.
I appreciate you guys.
...you should put,
in my opinion,
"Tank's Good News"
on the cover.
And if you get a chance
to go back to the warehouses
and get, you know...
Put a sticker.
...64,000 stickers
with your face on it,
with your Instagram
handles -- huge.
'Cause then there's
an immediate connection
for your millions
of followers.
Right.
So we'll put "Tank Sinatra,
Tank's Good News,"
we have a deal?
[ Laughter ]
You got a better shot,
seriously.
Thank you, guys.
Alright, good luck, man.
Good luck.
I could have asked for
less money based on the sales.
I based it more on
my presence online,
which was, in retrospect,
not the right thing to do.
But I'm such a big fan
of the show.
So just to get to be here
and meet them was a win for me.
Narrator: This season
of "Shark Tank,"
we've seen entrepreneurs
continuing to thrive,
even in the most challenging
times.
You're pushing a boulder up
the same hill every day.
There's problems
around every corner.
I have a soft spot
for entrepreneurs
because I respect
the journey so much.
Cole: No Limbits allowed me to
take something really terrible
that happened to me
and give it purpose,
and I'm really grateful
that I found mine through this,
even though it was
a painful journey to get there.
What are we gonna do?
Harrington: We had a major
logistics issue,
over 400 canceled orders.
We spent every moment
doing customer service.
We would say, "Please,
just give us an opportunity."
Riley: During the trade wars,
our tariff caused us
to have to raise prices.
Cuban: We had a conversation
about moving manufacturing
to the United States,
and you did it.
We have raised $100,000
for the FDNY Foundation.
To see what the Cup Board Pro
is doing in our dad's name --
it's so special.
I'm hoping for massive sales.
Baer: Since doing a deal
with Mark and Peter
only a couple months ago,
we've done over $8.7 million
in sales.
Haaber: We've sold more
than 85,000 goggles
and made more than
$4.1 million.
Since "Shark Tank,"
we've done over $57 million.
Krause: Scrub Daddy is one of
the top-grossing companies
in "Shark Tank" history,
doing over $670 million
in sales.
Narrator: They're innovating
and making a difference
in the world...
Demin: We're now at
400 weavers.
We've been able to infuse over
$2 million to the communities
where our hammocks
are made.
Skaya: We've gone
from a small company
to being part of
a $8 billion organization,
creating products
that will change the world.
Ulmer:
Since going on "Shark Tank"
when I was 9 years old,
we've been scaling the company,
saving the bees,
and inspiring the next
generation of changemakers.
You are the most powerful
generation we will ever have,
and I'm so proud of you all.
Narrator: ...and proving that,
with grit and determination,
anyone can be an entrepreneur.
Xu: "Shark Tank" is one of
the greatest platforms
to level the playing field
for the underdogs.
It gives equal access
to talent everywhere
so that collectively
we can all be successful.
I got to take my hat off
to my mom.
It takes a lot of guts
to migrate a country,
and it takes even bigger guts
to migrate
when you're 60 years old
to find a better future
for your son.
Moret: For any women out there
questioning if their idea
is good enough,
there's only one way
to find out.
When my mom first told me
she was proud of me,
it was amazing.
Kind of made it seem like this
is a business, this is real,
and this is success.
You're only bound
by your imagination.
To aspiring entrepreneurs,
tune in to "Shark Tank."
Listen to the stories
that those people tell.
They're real stories.
You, too, can get your idea
onto "Shark Tank"
and live the American dream
like we are.
♪♪
[ Drumming ]
Man: Go!
Narrator: Next up is a stylish
way to show your school spirit.
[ Drums playing ]
♪♪
Man: Go!
Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Cuban: Yeah, drummers!
Greiner: Very good.
Oh, wow!
Hello.
My name is Ashley Jones,
and I'm from
Virginia Beach, Virginia.
[ Drumming ]
[ Laughter ]
I'm the owner
of Tones of Melanin.
T.O.M.!
I'm seeking $300,000
for 5% equity into my business.
Hello.
So, Sharks, for years,
thousands of students,
faculty, and alumni
from historically Black
colleges and universities,
also known as HBCUs,
have been underrepresented
when it comes to fashion.
They're tired of
bedazzled T-shirts and polos
being their only option
for years.
Tones of Melanin is here
to fill that void.
Tones of Melanin
has combined streetwear
and collegiate wear
together
to create
its own genre of fashion.
To date, we have over
40 different HBCU licenses.
What makes us so unique
is that we come
from the community
that we serve.
Tones of Melanin has become
bigger than just fashion.
We've become the hub
for all things HBCU.
So, Sharks, who's ready to
change collegiate wear forever?
Give it up for my band!
[ Applause ]
Greiner: Whoo.
[ Drumming ]
♪♪
So, today,
in front of you,
you have some of
my signature items.
Mark, you have our reversible
basketball shorts with pockets.
I like that.
Ladies, we know that we have
to have pockets in all items.
So if you turn that thing inside
out, it's a whole nother pair.
I like it.
Thank you.
Right here, we have our
Winston-Salem
half-zip windbreaker.
In front of you,
Mr. Wonderful,
is our reversible
satin jacket.
So if you unzip that, it's going
to turn to a whole nother side.
Lori, you have our other
windbreaker.
It's a full-zip.
It gives you a blast
from the past, a '90s feel.
And, Daymond, you also have
our reversible jacket
from my alma mater,
Norfolk State University.
Nice quality.
How much does
it cost you to make,
and how much
do you sell it for?
The jacket that you have
right there,
we get it for $28.
We sell it on our site
for $110.
We sell it to
the department store for $56.
The reversible shorts
right there, we get for $20.
We sell it to
the department store for $48.
They sell it for $100.
Our reversible jackets,
we pay $30 for that.
We charge $165.
How did you start to do this,
and what's your background?
So, I designed from early
high school into college.
It became a side hustle.
I began designing for
every organization on campus,
and I seen there
that nothing looked
like the things
that I was designing.
So I decided
to start my own brand.
At the beginning,
I was doing Greek apparel,
and then I decided
to make HBCU apparel
because I seen that there was
a bigger need in that community.
And how many HBCUs,
or, you know,
historical Black colleges
and universities,
how many of those exist?
Depending on the person,
some might say 100,
some might say 102.
And you have 40 licenses
already in existence?
Yes.
So that's great.
You have almost
half of them, right?
Yes. But the thing is,
I've gotten our license
for everybody
that allows it.
The other schools,
they don't have
licensing programs
in place.
They don't have
licensing programs in place?
Yes.
That might be an opportunity
for you right there.
Absolutely.
So, very big.
The number-one shoemaker
in the world
has just invested,
I think,
a couple billion
over 15 years to HBCUs.
Yes.
So this is a very, very hot
and fast-growing area.
I tell you, what gets me
hot to trot is sales.
Yes.
What do you got?
To date, we've made $3.3 million
since --
-Whoo!
-Whoa!
The total over
what period of time?
Since 2017.
So what have you sold
the last 12 months?
The last 12 months,
we're at $1.4 million.
Wow.
Can you walk me through
this calendar year's sales
and potential profits?
And how they break down,
online versus retail?
Okay, this calendar year so far,
we've made about $1.1 million.
That equals up,
I want to say, maybe 75%.
The rest are e-commerce.
We're currently in
Dick's Sporting Goods,
Follett, which services 25
of the HBCU bookstores...
Wow.
...and also on Fanatics.
Literally two days ago,
I got a purchase order
from Follett
for $973,000
for our fall.
-Wow.
So...
Greiner: Good for you.
How exciting.
So, are you gonna
make money this year?
Yes, we are.
What do you think
you'll make?
To date, we revenue --
we have $343,000
that we made this year
from the 1.1 --
Okay. So you've profited
about 25% so far.
Yes.
You've got a purchase order
for $973,000 coming in.
Yes, sir.
Plus, you've got all your
other sales that are coming --
And then, also, we have
more department stores.
How are you
financing them?
We have a really good
manufacturer.
He allows for us to pay him
after we get our payment.
Wow.
John: Now,
this is very creative,
and this is what,
in our business,
we call the factories
holding the paper.
Yes.
That's what we called it,
right,
and a lot of people
can learn from this.
So you were able to scale
because he's doing that.
So, what would the money
be used for, then?
The money would be used for --
we're actually in-house.
We have a five-person team.
So once they get here,
we have to tag them, all that.
I want to go into fulfillment
and having a 3PL company tag it,
getting it ready
for department stores
to make sure that that's right.
Well, you don't have to pay
for a 3PL per se.
You find a good 3PL,
and then you send them
the inventory,
and then you only pay
as they pick and pack.
Ship them out.
Yes. We would also use it
for marketing.
We've only spent $50,000
in marketing.
But do you need to spend
anything on marketing?
I honestly believe
that we do,
because all the stores
that we're in,
we're not even --
we don't have, like,
a key place in the store.
We actually wanted,
those other schools
that we don't have
licensing for,
convincing them,
"Hey, choose us."
Yeah, marketing
won't change their mind.
The sell-through will.
Okay, yeah.
Are you running this
yourself?
Yes, I'm head designer.
I'm talking to
the manufacturers.
This is your baby and
you're running it day to day,
or is there
a separate CEO?
No, I'm day to day.
You're everything, right?
[ Laughs ]
Every hat, every hat.
Ashley, I have to
ask you this.
I mean, your enthusiasm,
your confidence is...
It's amazing.
...huge...
Thank you.
...and amazing.
Can you please tell us
a bit more about your story?
Like, where did this
come from?
My grandparents had
one of the first
African-American beauty supply
companies in our area,
so I've seen
entrepreneurship firsthand.
And then,
when I turned 13,
my mom worked for
the Ford Company subsidiary,
they left Norfolk, Virginia.
So I went into hustle mode,
and it was like,
"I could at least pay for me
to go pay for lunch for myself,
I can pay to get my hair done."
So it just became second nature,
to be honest.
You had to take care
of you.
Yes, yes. And it wasn't --
my mom never asked this,
I just wanted to help.
Like, "I know I can do this
for myself,"
like, "I can handle this.
You don't worry
about that, Mom."
You're hot stuff --
You're killing it, Ashley.
My God.
Ashley, you've gotta be
putting money
in your pocket right now.
Not yet.
You're investing in inventory
continuously?
Everything is going right back
into the business.
You're not
making a salary?
You don't pay yourself
anything?
I pay myself
next to nothing.
I'm still trying to get --
How are you surviving?
I have a great community.
My family, my mom,
she believes in me.
That is really
mind-blowing.
Problem for me --
I don't know much at all
about this area.
I am not really
and never have really been
much in the apparel world,
nor in the sports...
I understand.
Greiner:
It's not really my thing.
And so,
for that reason,
I wish you good luck,
but I'm out.
I appreciate it.
Thank you.
You are on fire.
But this isn't a business
I know a thing about.
Sadly, I'm out.
Ashley, I look at it
as a inventory challenge,
because
the bigger you get,
the more capital
you're gonna need
to hold all these
different SKUs,
and more licenses, more SKUs,
more inventory, more capital.
That's what I've learned about
the clothing business.
It's not a business
I want to be in.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
Thank you.
The challenge I have
is I'm in this area
in certain aspects.
I either advise or own
companies in this area,
Eastman Golf
and Actively Black, FUBU,
and then another company
you may know of, AACA,
African-American Colleges --
Okay, yes, yes, I'm familiar.
So it would be challenging
for me to split hairs like this,
and I don't think I would be
giving you -- doing a service.
But I will
give you one idea.
Instead of having -- trying to
go to a lot of retailers,
we've had one
representative young man
and one representative
young woman at each school
who are the official sellers
of the goods,
and they get maybe $1,000,
$2,000 worth of product,
and sell it
however they want,
and they've been doing it
like that.
I would highly suggest
you do that.
But at this moment,
it's a conflict for me.
So, yeah, congratulations.
I appreciate your advice.
Thank you.
Absolutely. I'm out.
So, Ashley,
you're a superstar,
you're a force of nature.
You know your stuff cold.
I mean,
you didn't back down.
You kept a smile
the whole time.
Nobody fazed you
even the tiniest bit.
And, you know, being
in the business I am
with the Mavericks,
I know a few people that,
you know,
are excited about all this.
So I'll make you an offer.
Okay.
We'll see if you like it.
I'll give you the $300,000,
but I want 15%.
Can we do 12%?
Done.
[ Laughter ]
Corcoran: Wow.
John:
That was quick.
Good job!
You're the best.
Thank you.
That's awesome.
I'm so excited.
Congrats.
Thank you.
Excited, excited, excited.
Now go sell some stuff.
[ Laughs ]
Yes, absolutely.
Make me some money.
♪♪
Jones: I made a deal
with Mark Cuban,
like, one of the biggest Sharks
there is.
I provide a beacon of hope.
If I made it
and I went to an HBCU,
I'm providing the sense of hope
for anybody
that attended an HBCU.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is an accessory
to make your wardrobe
more versatile.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Brooke Knaus,
and I'm seeking $70,000
for 30% of my company.
Sharks, you know some things
about fashion.
Barbara, Lori,
I'm looking at you,
both looking
gorgeous today.
You are right on that.
[ Laughs ]
So you already know
that crop tops
are super hot right now.
But what do you do
when you have a cute top
that you want to turn
into a crop?
Well, you could...chop it
yourself,
but why ruin
a perfectly good shirt?
Or you could do
this bra tuck hack
that's really hot
on social media right now.
Whoa, Hannah! It's not
that kind of show, guys.
Hannah's just doing that tuck
that is so hot
on social media right now.
And, yes,
it keeps your shirts intact,
but the second you start
really moving around,
it just slips
right back out again.
So, Sharks,
what do you do
when those hacks
inevitably don't work?
Tucky!
Tucky turns any top
into a crop.
Here, Hannah, try this.
Tuck is an elastic band with two
silicone strips on the inside.
You just wrap it around
your waist,
securely fasten,
tuck your shirts
up and under,
and you have a lasting crop
that's secure, comfortable,
and best of all, no slippage.
Wow.
So, Sharks,
what do you think about this?
Tucky is a tool to unlock
your closets in a new way
and lets you style your clothes
in ways you'd never
thought of before.
So what do you say, Sharks?
Let's cut the crop
and get to tuckin'.
Very clever.
So this is it
in front of us?
That's it, yes.
Okay.
You each have your own Tucky
in front of you to try.
And if you need
any inspiration,
please just look
to our beautiful models.
Is the middle person wearing
this, as well?
That is indeed
a sweater over a romper.
And that is a great way
to transition your wardrobe
from summer to fall and extend
the wardrobe that you have.
Kendra here, with the pink shirt
and the blue jeans,
she's doing what I call
the no-bulk tuck.
So, she has
a very bulky sweater
that looks like
it's tucked into her jeans
without adding any extra bulk
to her waistband.
Are you wearing one?
I am wearing one right now,
yeah.
So why would you wear it
with this outfit?
I'm just curious.
Why do I need it
with this outfit?
Well, for example, if I were
to tuck this top into my skirt,
it would add more bulk
to my waistband,
which is exactly
what I don't want to happen
when I'm trying to make the most
of the figure that I have,
which does lead me
to why I created Tucky.
Okay. Yes.
Tell us your story.
So, I created Tucky
after I'd had my second child.
I was recently postpartum,
which meant that I felt a little
disconnected from the body
that I was living with.
In order to feel
back in touch with my body,
I was wearing sweatpants
and sweatshirts, matching sets,
but there's a lot of bulk
in those sets.
So I was tucking my top up
into my bra,
hiking my sweatpants up high,
and essentially creating
an hourglass figure
when I really didn't have one
again yet.
The problem was, I was playing
with my then-2-year-old
and my newborn on the floor,
picking them up,
playing with them.
My top would just slip
right back out.
So when I went online
to look for a product
that might solve this issue,
nothing existed yet.
And that's when I thought,
"If it's a problem for me,
it's probably a problem
for millions of other women."
And that's how
Tucky was born.
I get it.
You must have some sales.
I do.
I'm so glad you asked.
Let's talk about that.
So, I launched this year,
so we're looking at about
six months to date.
I've made $60,000
in gross sales.
-Okay.
-Yes.
60 -- all online,
direct to moms?
About 98% online.
I have a handful of boutiques
in Charleston, South Carolina,
that carry my belt.
Okay. What does it cost
to make this?
Landed,
packaging included, $5.
They retail for $30.
My net take-home profit has been
$40,000 so far this year.
So...
Greiner: Wow.
Okay.
Good for you.
That's a lot.
So, Brooke,
would I find you
all over social media
demonstrating this thing?
You would. I would
actually attribute
so many of my sales
to having gone viral on TikTok
within the first month or so.
What were you showing?
Well, I was sort of debunking
that bra tuck hack.
Women were doing that.
It was a very popular hack
on social media at the time.
And, you know, I said,
"There's a better way."
Cuban: Look, Brooke,
great product.
Thank you.
My daughters, probably,
will love it,
and I'll make sure
to bring this to them,
my 16-
and my 19-year-old.
But it's really not
a fit for me.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
Thank you so much.
But congrats.
You've really taken this idea
and done a great job
with it.
Thank you so much.
You're welcome.
Okay. I think
it's a clever idea.
I think -- I'm not sure
how big the market is for it.
So while I think you have
a great little business for you
and I think you will do well,
I don't think it's the right
business for me as a partner.
So I wish you good luck,
but I'm out.
Thank you so much.
And I actually would love
to address a few things that
you just mentioned.
So, Tucky's primary market
is between the ages
of 17 and 25 years old.
There are 15 million women
in the U. S. alone
in that demographic.
You know what I love
about this business?
It's so simple.
You have one SKU,
and it sells for 30 bucks.
Makes sense.
What I don't like
about the product
is I think tucking,
cropping is a trend,
and I'm worried about
what happens
when it goes the other way,
the trend.
That --
I hope
I'm wrong on that.
I'm out.
Well, thank you so much.
Okay, so, Brooke,
I -- I'm impressed.
I mean, really,
great presentation.
Thank you.
I'm a believer in you.
I'm going off my piste
a little bit.
That's a ski term.
I'm a skier.
Me, too.
Because I really can't see
myself doing TikTok
wearing this thing,
which is what I would do
with a product.
You'd better not.
I would give you
the $70K for 40%.
Ooh.
Wow. Um...
I'd like to make
a million bucks.
Me, too.
I'd like to blow this up.
And, Sharks, that is actually
why I wanted to go in here
and just offer a larger
percentage for less, because --
No, I think you were wise,
because it's very hard to
get a deal in "Shark Tank."
You picked the exact approach,
the right approach.
And now he's taking
a much larger percentage.
Knaus: A much larger percentage.
Well, it's the only option
you have so far.
So, do you own 100%?
100%.
I think it's a flier,
and I just want to beat Kevin.
So I'll give you the same
exact offer of $70,000 for 40%.
Greiner: Ooh.
Cuban: Oh, neither of those
is any good.
Oh, guys.
You'd be crazy
to take either one.
You can counter.
Would you do...39%?
♪♪
39%?
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, you got a deal.
Yeah! Whoo!
Oh, Lord. [ Laughs ]
What a hard negotiator.
How you doin'?
That's a first -- 1%.
Cuban: That's a first.
Thank you. I'm so excited.
Way to negotiate, Brooke.
Oh, my God!
You're a machine!
I just can't wait
to work with you.
Alright.
Mr. Wonderful, it would have
been an honor, as well.
Thank you so much.
Well, you did a great job.
Congratulations, Brooke.
Congrats.
Knaus:
I countered with just 1%
because I didn't want
to lose Daymond.
He's worked in fashion
for so many years,
and I think
he fully understands
what Tucky can do
for a woman's wardrobe.
His involvement
and his excitement
to have that much stake
in the company
is what's going to help
Tucky grow fastest.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is a convenient way
to bring more clarity
into your life.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks. I'm Mark Singer.
And I'm Kenzo Singer.
We're a father-and-son duo
from Santa Barbara,
and are here to ask
for $25,000 for a 5% stake
in our company,
EyeWris.
Sharks, I have a question
for you.
What do sugarless ice cream,
low-salt turkey bacon,
and cheese-free mac and cheese
all have in common?
They were all bought
by mistake
because I didn't have
my reading glasses with me
at the supermarket.
[ Laughter ]
And we had to eat
all that stuff.
Cuban: That's great.
People like my parents
who need reading glasses
know the frustration of not
having their readers with them
when they need them.
[ Laughter ]
But it doesn't always
have to be like that.
Actually, I'm wearing
my reading glasses right now.
With one hand,
in one motion,
and in one second,
EyeWris reading glasses
change from wristwear
to eyewear.
Greiner: Oh, my gosh.
There you go.
And back again.
That's pretty cool.
Corcoran: Wow.
Did y'all catch that?
John: It is cool.
Dad, why don't you show them
one more time.
Using our patented
memory metal bridge design,
EyeWris reading glasses
both spring open and snap shut.
How clever is that?
Greiner: Amazing.
To date,
EyeWris has received
four international
design awards.
Mark:
But more importantly,
EyeWris reading glasses
are fashionable.
[ Laughter ]
So, which of you
is interested in forming
a strategic
partnership...
To share our vision...
And allow the world to see
the power of EyeWris?
Huh.
Sharks, in front of you
are samples for you to try.
Cuban: Best pitch ever.
-Thank you.
-Best pitch ever.
[ Laughter ]
You know,
it's really clever.
Now, I have
a very small wrist,
and it fits.
Are there
different sizes?
Oh, it's only got little
baby stems.
Or is it all one size?
We're starting out with
a universal, one-size-fits-all,
so it should fit
most everyone.
About 95% of the population
is what we're going for.
And you have a patent
on this.
So, I see right there,
it looks like a utility patent.
Mark: That's correct.
We have a utility patent
in the United States,
China, Japan,
and soon to issue
in 26 European countries.
These grippers, do they leave
a mark in your skin
if you're wearing these
for like an hour?
That's
a great question.
I've been wearing them,
sometimes 24/7, for months,
and they may
leave a little bit,
but nothing
that has been bothersome.
They're reading glasses.
They're not long term,
you know,
to keep on your head.
They're meant for
on the go.
Kenzo:
That's exactly right.
These are designed for
the dozens and dozens
of times a day
that you need to take them off,
put them on, check your phone.
One hand, one motion,
one second.
And what do you
sell them for,
what do they cost you
to make?
Greiner: Yeah.
So, they cost us $30.50.
That's landed, in our warehouse,
ready to go.
We sell them for $110 online,
and that includes free shipping.
Are you an inventor?
Yeah, for me,
it was
a need-based product.
As I got older, I needed
reading glasses more and more,
and they were never with me
when I needed them.
I thought the solution was
to buy a dozen pair...
Isn't that the truth?
...and put them
everywhere.
I still didn't have them
when I needed them.
Fortunately,
my son had an eye on me,
and he came up with the --
Are you an engineer?
Yes, I have a bachelor's
and a master's degree
in structural engineering
from Cornell University.
Oh, interesting.
And, Kenzo, how did you come up
with the idea?
How did you figure it out?
I was working as
a structural engineer,
and I designed everything
from skyscrapers
to soccer stadiums,
and thought that,
you know,
"Hey, physics at the scale of
a skyscraper also applies
to something as small
as a pair of reading glasses."
So I just kind of
applied what I knew
to come up
with this mechanism
that's both stable open
and stable closed.
We spent a weekend in
his woodshop prototyping it,
figured it out, and once we got
a working prototype,
we thought,
"Hey, this could work."
And that's when I quit
my engineering job
and did this full-time.
Wow!
Mark, what was your reaction
when your son outwit you?
Wow!
[ Laughter ]
If you think starting
a business is tough,
try doing it
with your kid.
Try doing it with your dad.
Oh, my God.
We just didn't hear
Mark's background.
What's your background?
Well, um, I left home
at about 15 1/2,
barely graduated
high school,
never got out
of college.
I'm mostly
a woodworker.
For over 60 years, I've been
designing and making furniture,
although along the way,
I have started some companies
and brought a number
of products to market,
including one you might
actually be aware of.
Which one was that?
Gorilla Glue.
O'Leary: Oh, wow. Gorilla Glue.
Gorilla Glue?
That's yours?
You're kidding!
Yeah.
Cuban: Gorilla Glue!
I have a bottle of that
back at the hotel
right now.
Corcoran: Wow!
That's what he pastes
his hairpiece with.
[ Laughter ]
John:
And you sold that?
That's a massive
company now.
Yes, I did sell that
years ago.
Excellent. Wow.
Was that a good outcome
for you?
Every company that I've
ever sold has included
a royalty component,
so yes.
[ Corcoran laughs ]
Oh.
So it's worked out
very well.
Oh, you know,
did you say royalty?
I did, sir.
Outstanding.
Wow.
Good man.
So, how many have you sold?
Tell us about your sales.
So, our website technically went
live at the end of last year.
These first nine months
have been a testing
and optimization period,
in terms of our website.
During this
testing period,
we've actually managed to do
about $28,000 in sales.
I know that sounds low,
so let me give you
some context.
Now, the last thing
I wanted to do was
to irresponsibly throw
a bunch of my dad's money
into marketing
in order to pump up our sales
in an inefficient way.
Smart guy.
So we've really only been
spending about $45 a day,
on average, on ads.
And even with
a low sales volume,
we're actually managing
to turn a small profit.
We're only selling direct
on our own website.
Sorry, I just want to ask
how much money you have
in the business.
I put about $630,000 into it.
Whoa!
Wow.
Whoa, that's a lot.
Whoa!
O'Leary: But because
you're a royalty guy,
you don't need the money,
right?
I mean --
Corcoran: 630...
Why do you need a Shark?
Your most valuable commodity
isn't your money.
It's your time.
You can always make more money,
but you can't make more time.
And time gone by
is gone forever.
[ Sniffs ]
[ Chuckles ]
♪♪
I don't have it in me
to build another company.
My time has passed.
My main reason for being here
is to leave Kenzo in good hands.
And by that,
I mean with successful,
smart, honest, and ethical
people like yourselves.
Wow.
I love you, baby.
I definitely want
to make you an offer,
'cause I'm so impressed
with you.
And, I mean,
it's just...
John: Hey, Kevin, hold on.
Kevin.
What's going on
with Lori?
Mark: Yeah, please, Lori.
I'm okay.
I'm sorry.
What? You all right?
O'Leary: While you're crying,
I'm gonna make an offer.
I'm sorry, that just --
it just really
touched me.
I'm -- You know...
We all have
limited time here,
and it just -- it just
really impacted me,
the way you were saying that,
you know,
you've, like, done your thing
and that you just want
to make sure
that your family's okay.
Um, it -- it just got me.
So, forgive me.
Um...
Listen, I just want
to make you an offer.
I'd like to offer you
$25,000 for 10%.
I know this business.
I know what it takes.
I've done millions of dollars
in sunglasses and readers,
and I think that
this was pretty ingenious.
It's great quality,
and I can put my heart
and soul behind it,
but it'll take work.
And I'd just like to take
the journey with you.
Thank you, Lori.
Really appreciate it.
O'Leary: I would also like
to make an offer.
I know how
to blow this up huge,
and I'm gonna give you
$50,000 for 10%.
This is an extraordinary
situation.
There's no question about it.
It's such a simple product
to demonstrate.
It's going to work
so well on social.
Cuban: But, guys,
I have a strong sense...
But he doesn't have the
experience that I have.
...that this is not about
the cash coming in.
So now we turn it
back to you.
What is it that you truly want?
We understand the goal,
but what is your
decision-making criteria?
So, yeah, you know,
we have the design done,
we have the patents,
we have new products coming out.
What we don't have
is the know-how
for how to best
get it out there.
I have that.
I've done this.
I've walked this lane.
Corcoran: But who would
you rather leave --
Who would you rather have
as a mentor for your son --
Lori or Kevin?
Cuban: Or all of --
Or multiple or whatever.
That's where I'm trying
to get to, right?
Because you have
a lot of flexibility.
All the leverage
turns back to you,
because we all know
this is a great deal,
and we all know
we can help you sell more.
There's three
components --
retail and online
and licensing the technology
for wearable --
for wearable tech.
That's your big play.
Yeah, that's your big play.
John: I think it's
a sports play, as well.
And I've been here
14 years.
Lori is one of
the smartest people...
Thank you.
...that I've ever met
in my life.
I'll double
whatever she has,
if she allows me
in the deal.
I'd be happy to work
with Daymond.
He's absolutely brilliant
in the licensing field.
10% is too much, Lori.
We're essentially
giving away the equity
for what you guys bring,
which is to some extent
invaluable.
So you don't want to give away
as much equity.
Two of you --
That's correct.
Well, Mark,
let me ask you a question.
Would you consider
giving more?
It sounds like
what you're saying is
you don't want
to go past 5%,
but if you got three Sharks,
would you give up 10%?
Yes.
Let's do that deal.
I want in this deal, too.
I'd love to be in the deal,
too, obviously.
Well, I don't
want to be left out.
What would you give up
for all the Sharks,
if we all want
in this deal?
♪♪
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in,
and they are all interested
in Mark and Kenzo's
innovative reading glasses
company, EyeWris.
Mark and Kenzo, what would
you do for all five Sharks?
What would you part with?
What would work for you guys
if, heaven forbid,
all five of you could work --
would work together?
You know, the way multi-Shark
deals typically work,
someone does the due diligence,
and then we all figure out
what our skill sets are,
and then we contribute those.
Okay, guys, why don't you step
into the hall so the Sharks
can talk this over,
you can talk it over...
[ Greiner laughs ]
...and we'll do some work here.
So, give us one second.
-Okay, so we'll...
-Thank you.
So what I'll suggest is really,
really simple, right?
It's not the cash. He's got
all the cash he needs, right?
Yeah, it's not the cash.
It's the aggregate equity.
Wow.
Unbelievable.
Okay. Um...
So what are you thinking,
percentage?
I don't think that we should
go more than 15%.
Let them work it out.
15%.
We all love this deal.
What's important is putting
yourself in their shoes, right?
Yes, that's right.
So, we can come in
and say, right,
"So, Lori can get 7%.
I'll take 3%."
You schmoes can take 5%,
right?
That's fine, right?
That's a total of 25%.
Greiner: Thanks, Mark.
And then what
we come back is
we each give $25,000,
because --
There's only one problem.
He has never said
he'd even entertain 25%.
Well, we're gonna find out.
He didn't say no.
It's...unexpected.
Unexpected.
We didn't even prepare
for this one.
No, we didn't.
Mark, Kenzo,
come back to the Tank.
♪♪
[ Kenzo exhales sharply ]
Guys, just before you start,
what's happening here
is almost unprecedented
in "Shark Tank" history.
You know that.
Every single Shark
wants to back you guys.
Thank you.
Practically never happens.
♪♪
Greiner:
Here's our offer.
We'd like to offer you
$125,000 for 25%.
You'll get all five Sharks.
What do you say?
♪♪
[ Corcoran laughs ]
I think -- I think...
I can't wait
to hear what he says.
♪♪
How about 20%?
You got a deal.
Cuban: Yes!
John: Done!
Thanks, guys.
Thank you so much.
Wow!
It's a love fest.
Cuban: Congratulations, man.
Thank you so much.
[ Indistinct chatter ]
Congratulations.
Thank you so much.
Kenzo: Couldn't be happier.
Couldn't be prouder of my dad.
My dad's never -- I've never
seen him get emotional like that
and seen my dad really speak
from his heart.
Yeah, it made the moment
pretty special.
Unbelievable.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, my God.
Dad --
I don't know what to say.
[ Both laugh ]
♪♪
-- Captions by VITAC --